at this point though you know the world
of success is different of course money
is different your family's a little more
secure a lot more secure not a little
more a lot more secure um you know is
there any inklet of
while this is now my career and the days
and you know the old
of me doing radio and and really getting
my chops together wow okay it could have
been for this thing i'm trying to find
if there was ever a a mental clique of
i can be the [ __ ] at this
yeah yeah there was i think it was
weirdly if i had to like
isolate it we made this video
i'm [ __ ] matt damon which became a
big viral video and it changed it
changed a lot it it really changed the
show because suddenly celebrities wanted
to be on it
which they didn't before i mean like if
you go if you ever have the
don't by the way but if you ever like go
back and watch the early shows like
there were times where
the the guests weren't even paying
attention to me like they were talking
to the other guests it felt like every
party i ever was at where i'd be sitting
there at the desk and they'd be carrying
a conversation i was like uh hmm should
i interject
what's what should i do now and the show
was live and it was just a mess and we
had sometimes we had really we were
really scraping the bottom of the barrel
when it came to stars
you have like the sixth most interesting
person on joe millionaire or something
you know not even joe we were like all
right if we have them could we maybe get
joe
oh joe's doing leno joe's uh
joe's not available but um
it's true
in fact that's why i started making fun
of matt damon because at the end of a
show we had some terrible guests and i
was standing there i'm wrapping up the
show and i'm standing there with these
guests and i don't even remember who
they were and i go i want to apologize
to matt damon we ran out of time for him
and i just did it to make our producer
jason laugh you know and he was cracking
up and uh then i just did it again the
next night and then
um i started doing it all the time it's
just you know
however
here's what i'm laughing all right
there's no way
there's no way not to be aware like when
you say yeah we're kind of scraping the
bottom of the barrel like you know when
you're looking you're looking at your
guests and you're like oh man all right
well
this is this yeah
and then they're looking at their
booking at my show and going who's this
i had mike tyson on the show for a week
he was my co-host you know
and and i was really excited because
mike tyson is you know i was a sports
guy here in l.a has been a central fit
you know if you do sports comedy
mike tyson that's it you know that's as
good as it gets
and he it was like it was only a week
but it seemed like we spent a year
together it was
incredible like one night i had him
sucking helium out of a balloon and
talking like he used to
and um one night we had ali landry the
doritos girl on the show do you remember
her and mike was so taken by her he was
like he was crazed he was in a just a
sexual frenzy
and i i remember thinking like oh no i
was
what do i do like what will i do
if he grabs hold of her and i started
looking around my desk i'm like all
right this phone is kind of heavy i'll
hit him with this
maybe that'll be quick enough that i can
get security to come in i have real like
i have real tears man this is this is
before mike tyson's like in the
fresh mike tyson yes
i'm laughing because one day i truly
know that you're serious i love mike
tyson and i genuinely do love him as a
person and
um one day
my son i was shooting a christmas song
with mike tyson we were singing um
uh sleigh bells ringing and the whole
the whole reason i did because i wanted
to hear him uh and sing certain words in
the song i don't remember what he was
coming up with the bits is this you and
your team yeah yeah yeah we came up with
it and he was always game for something
and um
we had like an hour or something you
know it was a hard out type of situation
and i get a call that my son is like
misbehaving at school and i got to go to
the school
so i'm like mike i'm really sorry i i
have to go to my son's school
i got an issue i have to deal with and
he's like yeah okay go ahead i'll wait
so he waits and oh glistening was the
word i wanted to hear him sing
glittening
so
uh i go i pick up my son i bring him
back to the show you know we have a talk
in the car and mike i get back mike's
like where's your son i said uh oh he's
you know he's out there he's
you mind if i talk to him i said go
right ahead and mike sat down and like
talked to my son and i kind of stood in
back so i could overhear it and he
talked to him my son was probably
10 11 years old at the time and he's
like you know i had problems in school
and but you really have to you know you
have to
try your hardest and like he gave him
this like this pep talk that i was just
like wow we don't know this guy at all i
mean people don't know who this person
is wow
you